have two kids yes how's that going
they're fine they're good that's the
most honest reaction I've heard from any
celebrity that's really cool good thing
I mean are you worried about your
children you know it's like they're
gonna be okay socially you know mm-hmm
they're gonna be left handed yeah one of
my boys think it's a boy he has red hair
oh you have a red head yeah and I was I
was walking with him the other day and
in the distance a few feet away I see
this really ugly redheaded man about my
age and I said an hour walking by him
and I hear the ugly man say to his
friend about my child I used to look
just like that as a kid
my son's gonna be ugly yeah no he's not
let me be the one to tell you why
redheads turn out to be real ladies
magnets the hell was that that was just
a chilling silence they weren't buying
it buying it all out at all no let's
talk about the fact that I other thing I
might have many things about you but
you're really you're very cool about I
think sheltering your family and your
kids from from show business in the and
the spotlight does your older son who's
old enough to like kind of know what's
going on is he does he know what you do
for a living
no he's four yeah 14 no he's four I just
I don't really cuz I don't know what to
tell I don't know what I do for a living
I mean I I know what I do but I don't
want him to know yet right but because I
have a show that's out right now and
there's billboards they put billboards
of your billboards for baskets
everywhere I mean I see your face all
the time on buses and you know well I
appreciate you saying that
I never see your face
wait on the night I passed you and your
son just a couple days ago why you were
wearing that who farted t-shirt it's an
heirloom but so my son and I were
driving around and he saw a billboard
with my face on it hmm
and he's like daddy you're up you're up
there I was like yeah I didn't know what
to say I just said yeah I did that I put
that up there you put that up yeah it's
normal son right a lot of dads do it
they do that they just put their faces
on billboards
yeah so he doesn't really know you know
it's kind of confusing I haven't really
figured that part out really how to
explain that part
you